♪ (music) ♪
(Derek) Thanks.
(applause)
Okay, thank you, Jeff.
And wow, it's really amazing to see
how people are using TensorFlow
to make the world a better place.
So, as Jeff said, my name's Derek Murray.
I work on the core TensorFlow team.
I'm thrilled to be here
at the second day of the summit
to tell you about tf.data,
which is our new library
that helps you get all of your data
from cat pictures to cassava pictures
into TensorFlow.
So why are we here talking
about input pipelines?
After all, they're usually overshadowed
by the more glamorous aspects
of a machine learning job,
the matrix multiplications,
and the convolutions.
But I now hear that they're actually
extremely important,
because input data
is the lifeblood of machine learning,
and their current algorithms
and hardware are so thirsty for data
that we need a powerful input pipeline
to be able to keep up with them.
That's the button. There we go.
Alright, so when I kicked off
the tf.data project last year,
TensorFlow had room
to improve in this regard.
You can either feed in data from Python
at each step, which was kind of slow,
or you could set up
queue runners to feed your data,
and these are a little challenging to use.
So, I decided to focus on three themes
which are going to be
the main topics of my talk today.
First is performance,
because when we're training models
on state-of-the-art accelerator hardware,
like Cloud TPU pods,
or NVIDIA GTX supercomputers,
we have a moral imperative
to keep those accelerators busy
with new data at all times.
The second is flexibility,
because we want to be able to handle
any kind of data in TensorFlow itself.
We don't want to have
to rely on external tools
so that it's possible to experiment
with different views of your data
on an interactive time scale.
And then, third, we have ease of use,
because as Jeff said,
our overall mission with TensorFlow
is to open up machine learning
to users of all abilities.
And I know from spending
a lot of time on stack overflow
that it can be a big leap
from following along
with your first MNIST tutorial
to training your first model
on your own data.
And a good input pipeline [story]
can help smooth this transition.
So we aim to make tf.data
the only library you need
for all input processing in TensorFlow.
How do we go about that?
Well, we took inspiration
from the worlds of databases
and functional programming languages,
and designed tf.data as a library
of simple composable tools
that we can divide up into three buckets.
First, we have the tools to extract data
from a wide range of sources.
These can range from in-memory erase
to multiterabyte files
that are sharded across
the distributive file system like GCS.
Then we have the tools
to transform your data,
and these enable you
to change the representation,
extract features from your data,
perform data augmentation,
and ultimately convert
your raw data into the tensors
that you'll use to train your model.
And finally, we have a set of tools
for loading the transformed data
into the memory of your GPUs
and TPU accelerators,
and this can be particularly important
for M2M performance
as we'll talk about a bit later on.
Well, that's the high-level pitch,
but what does it look like in real code?
Well, this is the standard tf.data
input pipeline for reading out
a set of example protos
from a set of TFRecord files.
And I bet that 90% of all
TensorFlow input pipelines
start off this way.
In fact, it's so common,
we've wrapped this very pipeline up
in the single utility function,
but just for pedagogical reasons,
it's useful to spell out
the individual parts.
So we start the extraction phase
by getting a list of files,
and these can be on your local disc
or just as easily in GCS or S3,
and we extract
the TFRecords from those files.
Then we use a sequence
of functional transformations
to pre-process the data.
And here we took inspiration
from languages like C#, Java, and Scala,
which choose method chaining
to build up a pipeline of dataset objects
and high order functional operators
like map and filter
to let you customize
the behavior of that pipeline.
And then, finally, in the load phase,
we tell the TensorFlow
how to get data out of the dataset.
One of the easiest ways
to do this is to create an iterator,
and just like its namesake in Python,
this gives you a sequential access
to the elements of the dataset.
A sequential access
is typically what you want
when you're doing mini batch training
for a deep neural network,
and we'll see some ways to soup up
this part of the pipeline later on.
Now that I've given you an overview,
I want to come back
to each of our key themes
and tell you how we've been advancing
each of them over the last few months.
Let's start with performance--
so you remember
all those exciting performance results
that Megan told you about in the keynote?
Well, every one of them was measured
using real input data
and a tf.data input pipeline,
you can download and use
in your own programs.
And in our set of benchmarks
there's one experiment
that I personally like
and it measures
the performance of training
an infinitely fast image model
on real data
in order to tease out
any bottlenecks in the tf.data pipeline.
And when we ran this benchmark
last week on an NVIDIA DGVX1V,
it managed to process
over 13,000 image net images per second.
Now that is actually much faster
than we can train a state-of-the-art model
on current hardware,
but it's still exciting
for a couple of reasons.
And first of that, out of all of them
is that this throughput
has more than doubled
over the past eight months,
and it's really a testament
to the great job the whole team has done
in optimizing TensorFlow performance.
And the second reason
is that accelerator's models
are getting faster all the time,
so we're in a good place to deal
with future generations
and we've got
this extremely useful benchmark
which guides us as we continue
to improve tf.data performance.
So these results
are all very nice in theory,
but how do you actually get
that kind of performance?
Well, one option is you can go and get up,
fork the TensorFlow benchmarks project
and use that code in your own program.
If you're training a model and image now
you should probably just do that.
But, maybe you have
a different problem to solve
so we've recently launched
a performance guide
for tf.data on tensorflow.org,
and this guide is full of useful
theoretical and practical information
that gives you the ability
to put our optimizations into practice
on your own pipelines.
To support this on the technical side,
we've been adding a raft
of new features to tf.data
to help achieve this performance.
One that I particularly want to call out
is this new GPU prefetching optimization
that's going to be a part
of TensorFlow 1.8,
although you can start playing with it
on the night we build, right away.
And up to this point,
tf.data has been exclusively for codes
that runs on the CPU,
and this marks our first foray
into running pipelines on GPUs as well.
There's a lot more I can say on this topic
and we're still developing these features,
so watch this space.
But let's go back to looking again
at our program from earlier on.
I'll show you how to put
some of these techniques into practice.
So first off, when you're dealing
with a large dataset
sharded across a cloud storage service,
like GCS or S3,
you can speed things up
by reading multiple files in parallel
to increase the effect
of throughput into your model.
You can now turn this on
with a single option
to the TFRecord dataset
called num_parallel_reads.
Then, in the transformation phase,
you can often improve performance
by switching to fuse the versions
of various transformations.
So here I fuse shuffle and repeat
that avoids a stall
between epochs as it buffers.
And I've also fused together
the map and batch transformations
which paralyzes both the execution
of the function in the map
and the data transfer
of each element into the batch tensor,
and together these two optimizations
get big speedups
for models that consume
a large volume of data per step.
And last but not least,
we have the GPU prefetching
that I just mentioned.
So this ensures
that the next batch of input data
is in memory on the GPU
when the next step is ready to begin.
And this optimization
has been a crucial part
of our CNN benchmarks for a while now,
but achieving it involved
manually staging buffers
from the CPU memory to GPU memory,
so changing up the structure
of your program to do this.
The new prefetch to the device API
gives you the same performance
and only requires you to add
one line of code to your input pipeline
to get the benefit.
So this is really just
the CliffsNotes version.
I encourage you to watch
my colleague Bren Saeta's talk
later here at the summit.
He'll show you a more scientific approach
to pipeline performance optimization.
And of course, you can check out
the performance guide
on tensorflow.org.
So now let's switch gears
and move on to our second theme
which is flexibility.
And originally,
the flexibility in tf.data stemmed
from the functional transformation.
So they allow you to put
any TensorFlow computation,
any fragment of a TensorFlow graph,
at any point in your pipeline.
And so, for example, if you have
some existing TensorFlow code
for pre-processing images,
you can stick it inside a dataset.map
and start using it
in your pipeline right away.
An initial version of tf.data
had sort of traded on this
and it let you pass a list of tensors in
and get a list of tensors out
from these transformations.
But we heard back from our users
that they had more sophisticated things
and complicated feature structure.
So we had a support
for nested structure types
like tuples and dictionaries.
And in TensorFlow 1.5, we had
a native support for sparse tensors,
which are particularly useful
when you're dealing
with complex categorical data
and training embedding models.
So, at this point,
if there are TensorFlow ops
for everything you want to do,
then you're all set.
But one thing that we've learned
over the last few years
is that not everything
is most naturally expressed
as a TensorFlow graph.
So we've been working
to give you alternative ways
to build up your tf.data pipelines.
The first way is by adding
Dataset.from.generator,
and what this allows you to do
is build a pipeline from a Python function
that generates [non PyRates].
And this gives you the flexibility
to wrap existing Python code in a dataset
and benefit from some
of our performance optimizations
like prefetching to GPUs.
The other way might be a little
more appealing to power users,
so we've opened up
the backend API to tf.data
and you can now build
your own dataset kernel plug-ins in C++,
and loading them using
TensorFlow's custom op mechanism.
We've already heard
from some of our partners
that this ability is useful
for integrating with custom file formats
and in-house storage systems.
And we're dogfooding this approach
for some of the new datasets
and limitations in tf.contrib,
like the recently added Kafka dataset.
So I'm really looking forward to seeing
what some of you will build
with this new API
and, of course, I'd encourage you
to contribute things back
via pool request.
We're really excited to get
contributions from the community
in this part of the project.
Okay, the final thing
I want to cover is ease of use.
I want to speak to folks,
maybe like some of you
who've used TensorFlow
for a year or more
and have struggled with the old ways
of reading data into TensorFlow.
I usually don't have to make
much of a case here.
But our users have
really high expectations
and there are new people
getting their first exposure
to the library every day.
So we've continued
to push hard on usability.
So I just want to share a few highlights
from recent months.
First off, as Rajat
told you in the keynote,
eager execution is here,
and it makes using tf.data
a lot more pleasant.
In the next talk, Alex is going
to tell you a lot more
about eager mode,
but from my admittedly bias perspective,
the best thing about it
is that you can start treating datasets
just like any other
iterable object in Python.
So you can simply loop over them
with a regular [for loop]
and there's no more
"make one-shot interator" required.
And what's really neat about this
is that it works together
with tf.data optimizations
like GPU prefetching.
So you can combine the efficiency
of asynchronous graph-based execution
for your input pipeline
and the flexibility of eager execution
for your model code.
Next, we've heard feedback
that while power users
like the compose ability
and configure ability of the data API,
many users just want an easy way
to follow best practices
on standard data formats.
So TensorFlow 1.8 will contain
new standard recipes
for tf.example protocol buffers
and for CSV data.
They make a lot easier
to handle these formats
and apply all of the best practices
from a performance guide.
So let's go for one last time
back to our standard program,
and as I promised in the beginning,
the whole thing can be replaced
with a single call
to make batch features dataset.
And this performs
all the parallel IO, parallel parsing,
shuffling, batching
and prefetching for you.
And it gives you back a dataset
that you can continue to transform
using map, filter,
and other transformations.
And if you have
a performance critical workload,
we generally recommend
using a binary format
like tf.Example and TFRecords.
But for many users
who are just getting started
and tend to have smaller data,
they often prefer something simple,
and comma-separated values,
or CSV format, fits that bill nicely.
And, in particular, we've noticed
how popular CSV data is on Kaggle
where there are thousands
of different CSV datasets
that are available to download for free.
And this snippet shows you
how to use the new Kaggle API
by pip installing Kaggle,
to download them with just a couple
of simple commands.
And once you've done that,
you can call the new make_csv_dataset
function in TensorFlow
to get the data
out of those dead unloaded files.
In this case, we'd say dataset
of a million news headlines,
and I think it's quite simple,
it's only got two features.
But what I particularly like
about this new API
is that it takes care of figuring out
the types and the caller names for you
and it dramatically cuts down
the amount of boilerplate
you have to write to work
with this kind of data.
Finally, we've been working
to improve the integration
between tf.data
and high-level TensorFlow APIs
like estimators and Keras.
Now the Keras support is still
in the pipeline, if you'll excuse the pun.
But if you want to switch
our CSV parsing code
for eager mode using estimators,
it's a simple matter
of returning the dataset
from an estimator's input function--
no more iterator required--
and then you pass that input function
to the estimator's train method
and we're good to go.
And really, the approach
we're taking on usability here
is to make tf.data objects,
like the datasets and the iterators,
as natural and pythonic as possible.
And features like eager execution
and the high-level APIs
are making this a lot easier to do.
Our eventual goal
is to make it so seamless
that your input processing infrastructure
becomes a natural extension
of your TensorFlow program.
Well, that is about all the time I have.
So just to recap.
I told you in the beginning
that our mission for tf.data
was to make a library
for input processing
that is fast, flexible, and easy to use.
I hope I've convinced you
in the last 15 minutes
that we've achieved
all three of these goals.
So you'll understand when I'll say
that tf.data is the one library
we recommend
for all input processing in TensorFlow.
If you want to find out more,
there is a ton of documentation
about tf.data on tensorflow.org.
We cover how-tos
and the performance guidance
that I mentioned earlier.
And both the TensorFlow benchmarks
and the official models repositories
have examples of high performance
and readable input pipelines
written in tf.data.
And with all of this information,
and knowing the real creativity
of this community,
I'm really looking forward to seeing
what all of you build with this library.
Thanks a lot for listening.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪